[Musique]
la 59e édition du Salon International de
l'Agriculture ouvrira ses portes ce
samedi 25 février Porte de Versailles à
Paris un jour de l'ouverture le village
réunion commence à prendre forme
à titre exceptionnel et au regard des
800 mètres carrés que nous avons il y a
une dérogation pour que le prestataire
puisse intervenir des Mardis et donc à
partir de mardi ce sont ils se sont
installés et ont commencé à livrer tous
les matériaux que vous que vont
constituer ces 32 stands ainsi que les
stands partenaires les stand
institutionnels donc à partir de jeudi
nous avons certains exposants qui qui
pourraient c'est un premier salon sont
venus se sont approprié les lieux parce
que il y a un changement de notoire
cette année c'est que nous sommes au
Hall 102 à l'étage alors que jusqu'à
jusqu'à maintenant nous étions situés au
rez-de-chaussée au Hall 50
ce vendredi les exposants récupèrent
leurs produits et peaufinent la
présentation de leur stand un mélange de
stress et d’excitation
et l'ambiance donc bon à mon avis c'est
seulement cet après-midi qu'on
vraiment sera un petit peu plus sur ses
lettres pour pouvoir présenter les
produits être de matin mais demain matin
sera prêt pas plus de stress que les
années précédentes
qui nous manquaient les accessoires etc
pour qu'on puisse préparer des
accessoires les bouillants les camos
voilà récupérer les produits qui nous
faut pour la dégustation des produits
quand on se sent bien on attend que
notre palette de produits arrive c'est
tout ça qui nous manque la préparation
et ben on est content d'être là et voilà
on est on est prêt d'attaque
pour 12 d'entre eux il s'agit de leur
première participation à ce salon
emblématique
[Rires]
et de participer à ça mais c'est un
grand événement pour moi et c'est de
l'ampleur voilà c'est très très grande
ampleur donc là on est en train de
mettre les étagères en place on attend
la livraison des pots et puis on va
aménager décorer s'organiser aussi voir
où est-ce qu'on place les différentes
accessoires les sacs en papier les
cartes de visite comment on dispose les
pauvres voilà faire l'aménagement du
stand pour que tu sois attrayant et
fonctionnel je pense qu'on en a pour
bien la journée vous êtes peut-être un
des petits débuts de soirée mais ça
c'est du boulot
la Réunion s'apprête une nouvelle fois à
briller par la qualité de ses produits
au Salon International de l'Agriculture
à Paris dès demain et pour 9 jours
[Musique]